with Trump losing what is next for the Republican
Party? This is a question I've received dozens of
times over the last week. The tougher question
for me about the GOP is what happens in the next
two weeks and two months? Do they back Trump? Do
they all start saying it's time to resign? Does
Trump try to do something crazy during the lame
duck? And if so, do Republicans get in the way
or do they just look the other way or do they help
him do it? The longer question about Republicans
seems pretty unambiguous to me. You've already
seen clips. I've played them for you this week
from Willard Mitt Romney and John Kasich. They're
immediately going back to standard Republican
talking points. We have to block Medicare
for all. We have to deal with the deficit,
which they didn't talk about at all under Trump.
Republicans are going right back to just being
Republicans. Once Donald Trump is gone. It also
has to be considered and I dealt with this earlier
in the week, I spent 10 minutes, 15 minutes
talking about it. Democrats failed to get a large
repudiation of Donald Trump. Donald Trump lost
by thin margins in three to four states. Trump
almost got reelected at the electoral level. And
although Joe Biden's popular vote margin is great,
Donald Trump got millions more votes than he got
in. Twenty, sixteen, seventy one million votes
for Donald Trump. When you get seventy
one million votes for your candidate,
even if you lose, especially if you think it
was stolen, you're not necessarily going to say
we need to change everything we're doing.
There may be changes at the state level.
Georgia, looking at Georgia, looking at how close
Texas was, you may see Republican strategy change
within some states in really particular ways, but
Republicans are going to continue to do well. And
anyone who says otherwise maybe is not aware
of the history of how quickly the two political
parties bounced back from losses and even from
big losses. This is not a big loss in the sense
that Republicans are gaining in the House.
They may even remain retain control of the
Senate. And and Trump got seventy one million
votes. So with Republicans being better at the
local level, with Republicans having better
ground game generally, but not always,
I am not expecting major changes in the Republican
Party. I'm expecting the Republican Party to
revert essentially back to what it was up until
Donald Trump became the nominee. I would expect
the Republican Party to continue using their wedge
issues, including those religiously tied issues
like abortion, less so gay marriage. But
now it's religious freedom to raise money,
although it may become a little bit more difficult
over time. But I'm not expecting major changes
other than a lot of Republicans who were with
Trump for the last four years who will pretend
they never were and even start to pretend Trump.
We don't we don't even remember Trump, really.
That is what I am expecting from them. So I don't
expect major changes to the Republican Party.
I think the next two weeks and two months will be
key in terms of who's with Trump and who is not
with Trump And the question of the Senate gets
us directly into question number three today.